في حوت متهم بانه جاسوس روسي يعني يمكن
تفكروا انه هذا الخبر مزحه وحقيقه لكنه في
الواقع حقيقه ودوليه كمان والموضوع له كذا
سنه يعني واليوم رجعوا برصدوا الحوت مره
ثانيه
[موسيقى]
القصه بدات في 2019 لما ننمسك حوت من نوع
بلوغا في القطب الشمالي قرب النرويج وكان
مربوط في جسمه معدات وان قال انه جاسوس
اللي شفناها هذه مشاهد لما شافوا اول مره
المعدات اللي لقيوها مربوطه فيه كان فيها
قاعده كاميرا وكان مكتوب عليها معدات
وهذا الشيء خلى النيروجين يقولوا انه في
الغالب جاسوس روسي وقالوا انه اتعودوا او
تعود هذا الحوت على البشر كان دليل على ما
يبدو انه تم تدريبه من قبل الروس على
التجسس وانه جاء من منشاه عسكريه روسيه
وسمو الحوت وقتها حتى هافال ديمير هافال
معناها حوت بالنرويجي ودمير اخذوها من
فلاديمير اسم بوتين الاول عشان يصير اسم
الحوت الحوت فلاديمير في اشاره للرابط مع
روسيا ووقتها موسكو ما ردت على اي من
الكلام النرويجي هذا امس وبعد اكثر من
ثلاثه سنين منظمه وانويل اللي هي منظمه
نرويجيه بديرها عدد من الشباب لانقاذ
الحيتان وحمايتها من الانقراض قالت انها
رصدت الحوت رصدت الحوت الجاسوس ثاني وهذه
المره في المياه السويديه وقالت انه كان
بيصير ببطء شديد ولكن بمراقبه تحركات
وشافوا انه بيصير بسرعه كبيره في الاشهر
الاخيره الى ان وصل الساحل الجنوبي الغربي
للسويد
السؤال اللي بيطرح نفسه هنا هو عادي كده
انه التجسس يصير بحيتان ولا الموضوع تخريف
اسئله كثير يعني بتدور في خاطري بصراحه
وتعالوا نسالها لضيفنا من عمان اللي هو
المحلل العسكري محمد ثلجي اهلا فيك معنا
استاذ محمد يعني ليش ممكن روسيا تكون
ليش ممكن روسيا كنتي بتتجسس بحوت
اولا سيدتي قبل البدء بالحديث اتمنى
العوده الميمونه ان شاء الله لرواد الفضاء
السعوديين ونبارك للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذا الانجاز ان شاء الله وان شاء
الله الى الامام وانجازات متكرره ان شاء
الله عربيه على هذا الصعيد وفي كل الصعود
ايضا وبالعوده للحديث عن الحوت والحوت ذو
الحظ العافر وربما انه ضاق ذرعا بمعتقله
ومن ثم فر هاربا يبحث عن الحريه وربما ان
هذا الحوت قد نسي مبدا هاما من مبادئ
الجاسوسيه وهو يجب ان لا تبدو ابدا كجاسوس
وهذا ربما ما قد نسيه الحوت وبالتالي تم
مراقبته والعثور عليه ومشاهدته وهو يتجول
بسرعه ببطء ومن ثم بسرعه حول في المياه في
المياه البحر وبالتالي اقترب من السواحل
النرويجيه والسويديه الى ان تم ربما
مشاهدته ومراقبته من اين ابتدا ومن اين
وصل وهذه سيدتي ربما تجسس هو نشاط اجتماعي
بشري قديم يبحث عن التحري عن المعلومه وعن
الخبر بصدق وبدقه حتى
يتم بناء تقدير
هذا هذا يعتمد على هذا الحوت وربما ما
يعني سيتم العثور عليه بعد ان يتم تحليل
مسير هذا الحوت ومن اين من اين انطلق والى
اين انتهى وكيف حل به يعني
المقامه ان ينتهي الى السواحل المقابله
وبالتالي ربما ان هذا الحوت قد خرج عن
السيطره وربما ان الاجهزه التي كانت يعني
قد وضعت على هذا الحوت ربما انه تم
ازالتها وبالتالي انطلق هذا الحوت من
معقله ووصل الى ما وصل اليه هذا الحوت
سيدتي بعد ان تم اكتشافه في 2019 بعد ان
تم اكتشاف الحوت الاول وتم تم فك الاجهزه
التي كانت يعني ملقاه او التي كانت حول
جسده وحيث اكتشف يعني الصيادين في ذلك
الوقت والعلماء البيولوجيين علماء
البيولوجيا البحريه بان هذه الاشرطه او
هذه الاحزمه التي كانت تلتف حول جسم الحوت
كانت معده لتركيب الكاميرات وبعضها معدلي
لاستقبال بعض الاسلحه او لتركيب بعض قو
اعد قواعد الاسلحه بحيث انها تستطيع تركيب
الاسلحه عليها وبالتالي يعني التحليل ان
هذا الحوت كان هو حوت للتجسس لالتقاط
الصور والمعلومات وربما كان عليه اجهزه
تنصت واجهزه انذار ايضا وربما كان معدل
استقبال الاسلحه او لتركيب الاسلحه عليه
استاذ محمد يعني هل طبيعي يعني انه في
حيتان جلسه بتشتغل جواسيس تابعه لدول يعني
بيدرجوهم يعني ضمن قوائم الجواسيس يعني
هذا متعارف عليه يعني في الاستخبارات يعني
سيدتي
تجنيد الحيتان او او تسخيرها او تطويعها
هذا علم قائم بذاته كما ذكرت بالبدايه
بانه يعني حينما حينما يعني استطاع
الانسان وعن طريق مراكز البحوث العلميه
واستطاعت اجهزه الاستخبارات يعني العسكريه
والامنيه من تطويع انواع كثيره من الحيتان
ومن الدلافين ومن يعني اسد البحر والفقمات
والطيور ايضا استطاعوا تطويعها واستطاعوا
تدريبها على القيام بمهام تجسسيه
واستخباريه وايضا على القيام بمهام
انتحاريه وهذا متعارف عليه منذ يعني منذ
زمن بعيد فكان لازم محمد يعني انت جالس
بتقول عالم البحار يعني دحين في عملاء
جالسين جواسيس جالسين يعني انت تذكرت كل
تقريبا انواع الناس اللي تحت البحر جالسين
وتحتفل او الحيوانات يعني خلاص بدات
تتعامل معهم الناس بيتجنند وجواسيس يعني
هو ده بعض انواع الاسماك بعض انواع
الاسماك ليست مشغوله سيدتي وخاصه اسماك
التونه و اسماك الهامور الاسماك التي نرغب
بالنتناولها هي ليست مشغوله من هذه
امانه هذولي اصحابنا ما في
نعم نعم
اوكي
واسد البحر وكلهم ايش في اشياء تانيه نحن
ما بنعرفها او ما هي خاطره في بالنا برضو
كمان اساليب يعني بتشتغل في عالم
الاستخبارات او جلب المعلومات
سيدتي عالم التجسس هو عالم كبير جدا وخاصه
فيما يتعلق يعني بالعمليات العسكريه
والعمليات والتجسس السياسي على المستوى
الكبير نشطت العمليات التجسسيه خاصه في
اعقاب الحرب البارده عقاب الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وعند بدء الحرب البارده فيما بين
المعسكرين الشرقي والغربي وكان هنالك نشاط
استخباري تجسسي كبير جدا ويعني اود ان
اقول يعني بان وكاله الوكاله المركزيه
للاستخبارات الامريكيه
قد استحدثت برنامجا في ذلك الوقت يسمى
اكوسيتك والذي هو القطه الصوتيه وكانوا
يحاولون من خلال ذلك الوقت ان يقوموا
بتركيب اجهزه تنصت واجهزه استشعار
واستقبال للاصوات على القطط بحيث يعني يتم
ارسالها الى المراكز المراكز الاستخبارات
الامريكيه وكان الهدف هو التجسس على
السفارات الاتحاد السوفياتي وسفرات الكتله
الشرقيه في ذلك الوقت ولكن هذا المشروع
بعد ان تم صرف عليه ما يقارب حوالي 15
مليون دولار عام 1961 فشل هذا المشروع
هنالك مشاريع اخرى سيد كثيره وكانت
التقارير تشير وقد اشارت مجله نيوزويك عام
2019 بان الاتحاد السوفيتي كان لدي مراكز
ابحاث في هذا الخصوص من تجنيد الدلافين
والفقرات ولا غير ذلك وتسخيرها لاعمال
التجسس واعمال المهام الانتحاريه هذه هذه
المراكز اغلقت ولكن اشارت تقرير اخرى بان
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين قد افتتح ثلاثه
قواعد لهذا النوع من التدريب في الدائره
القطبيه الشماليه وبالتالي لا يستبعد بان
هذه الدلافين التي تم الانقاذ عليها قد
فرت من هذه القواعد اوامر انه قد تم اطلاق
يعني صراحه عمدا بعد ان انتهت مهمه
بس يعني عندي سؤال الان يعني طب
الوسائل التقليديه في جلب المعلومات يعني
البني ادمين اجهزه التصنت الحلوه دي اللي
بتنحط الاشياء هذه كلها يعني ما هي كافيه
في شفنا الدرونز كمان يعني في اشياء
ممتازه يعني شغاله
والتصوير والاقمار الصناعيه جميعها يسهل
التعرف عليها ويسر اكتشافها ولكن في عالم
الجاسوسيه حينما تكون هنالك وسائل مبتكره
لا تخطر على البال ولا تسترعي الانتباه
ولا تستدعي الانتباه اضافه الى ذلك اود ان
اقول لك معلومه مهمه بان هذه هذه
الحيوانات هي امنه وامنه وكتومه ولا تدري
بمعلومات عمن جندها وهذا هو
معلومات عن احد من جنده يعني ايش حيعذبوه
ويعترف
والله بشتغل للروس مثلا
[ضحك]
ولذلك تستخدم ولذلك انتم استخدامها
لازم انا اليوم طب بس انت سؤال سريع اخير
الفقمه متاكد انه بيستخدموها في التجسس
لان الفقمه شكلها كسول مره يعني
اولا انا سعيد سعيد اني ادخلت الابتسامه
على يعني على محياك الطيب هذا من ناحيه
وهذه ما ادريت به هو حقائق وحقائق موثقه
وحقائق مكتوبه سيدتي ويعني
فعليا اليوم راح اقعد اقضي الوقت في جوجل
الموضوع هذا لانه فعلا مثير للاهتمام
وشكرا لك على يعني يعني طلعنا على عالم
جديد يعني بالنسبه لنا شكرا لك طبعا كان
معنا من عمان المحلل العسكري محمد ثلجي
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]